So now, I've written my stub. And I'm going to modify daysInMonth to be
correct for all months except for February in leap years. So, to do that, we've
got to know how many days there are in a month, and I need Wikipedia for this.
You may already know. Here we go. Here's the number of days in months. We have
31 days in January, March, and May, July, August, October, and December, so
let's write our code. And I'm writing this using only things we've seen through
unit 2. If I was writing this for real, I would do something a little bit easier
to type. And those are the 31 day months. An easier way to write this would be
to just list them all like this. That would mean the same thing but using a
topple. We'll keep things only using things we've seen through unit 2. So, if
the month is one of those, we return 31. If the month is February, we're going
to return 28. And this is the case we're going to have to do something more
complicated if it's a leap year, and otherwise we're going to return 30. So, at
this point, we should be able to add some tests, that should be correct now, if
we are not in a leap year, the day after February 28th is going to be March 1st.
And a month that has 30 days, let's pick one, is September, it'll be October
1st. I think that's enough. The other test case, I think it would be good. That
at this point, is something that looks at a whole year. If it's a non-leap year,
we should correctly have 365 days. Okay, so now I've got some more test cases,
and they should be correct, even for months that don't have 30 days, so let's
try. See if I made any mistakes. And all the tests finished, so it sounds like
they're correct.